RETO MEIER: Hello, I'm Reto
Meier for the Developer Show.
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Last week we hosted Google
I/O, our annual developer
conference.
If you weren't able to
join us or just want
to relive the
magic, you can find
the keynote and all
the sessions on YouTube
by following the link below.
Here's a taste of some
of the highlights.
We're excited to share with you
11 Jetpack libraries that can
be used in development today.
CameraX, now in
alpha, enables you
to create great camera-driven
experiences in your app
without worrying about the
underlying device behavior.
It gives you access to
the same functionality
as the native camera
app, including
features like portrait,
night, HDR, where supported.
Also in alpha there's
live data and life
cycles with coroutines.
View model with safe state,
and lots and lots more.
We also open sourced
an early preview
of Jetpack Compose, a new
unbundled tool kit designed
to simplify UI
development by combining
a reactive programming
model with the conciseness
and ease of use of Kotlin.
Find out more about
all these new Jetpack
APIs in the post below.
Android Studio 3.5 beta
is ready to download.
We heard that you wanted us
to focus even more on quality
and stability over features.
So we kicked off Project Marble.
Focused on making the
fundamental features and flows
of the IDE rock-solid.
Android Studio 3.5 is the
culmination of this effort.
Find out more about it
from the link below.
The Firebase team has launched
three more capabilities
in beta.
On device translation allows
you to use the same offline
models that support
Google translate
to provide fast dynamic
translation of text in your app
into 58 languages.
Object detection and
tracking lets your app
locate and track in real time
the most prominent object
in a live camera feed.
With AutoML vision
edge you can easily
create custom image
classification
models tailored to your needs.
Just upload your training
data to the Firebase console,
and you can use Google's
AutoML technology
to build a custom TensorFlow
Lite model for you
to run locally on
your user's device.
You can learn more about
these and other new Firebased
features in the blog
post shown below.
At I/O the Flutter team
announced an expansion
of their focus from mobile
to incorporate a broader set
of devices and form factors.
They released their first
technical preview of Flutter
for web, and
announced that Flutter
is powering Google's
smart display platform,
and delivering the first steps
toward supporting desktop class
apps with Chrome OS.
Furthermore, Chrome OS is a
great developer workstation
for building general-purpose
Flutter apps, thanks
to its support for developing
and running Flutter apps
locally on the same device.
To learn how you can target
Chrome OS with Flutter
and how to run the Flutter
development tools on Chrome OS,
you can follow the
instructions in the post below.
Open images V5 features
segmentation masks
for 2.8 million object
instances in 350 categories.
Unlike bounding boxes,
which only identify regions
in which an object is
located, segmentation masks
mark the outline of
objects, characterizing
their spatial extent to a
much higher level of detail.
We've put particular effort into
ensuring consistent annotations
across different objects.
Check out the post below to
learn more about open images
V5, and how you can participate
in the open images challenge.
Don't forget to check out
all the amazing Google I/O
sessions available on
YouTube and please remember
to like, subscribe, and share.
I'm Reto Meier for
the Developer Show.
Thanks for watching.
Yay, another new t-shirt,
just what I needed.
- You've already got two
closets full of them.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.